can a man not feel some sort of
responsibility or sort of think about
how that child might feel that's all it
is that was he doesn't know my child it
doesn't matter we are all parents of all
children if I see a child on the street
I care about how my child child feels
way more than anybody if you did you
wouldn't be doing only fans if I see a
child on the street you child you be
doing only fans listen if I see a child
on the street byel I care about that
child I do like I know it's crazy to me
you guys act like you act like you're
Reinventing the will you're not doing
anything you're not creating businesses
you're not what are you doing out there
she just said she cre can you stop
interrupting me you're being very rude
you keep you keep interrupting me do you
know what it is this is masculinity and
the problem is women always try women
always Tred to tone police from the
moment I've started I've not been rude
I'm having to now raise my voice you you
ra your voice from the beginning
aggressive guys let me show you what
women do he has not been r